go with the flow now that the chilling
adventures of sabrina series is over
we've all got some major questions
what's that spell the series was
notorious for loads of plot holes
likely due to all the material and
characters they tried to cover we'd
hoped maybe a next season would shed
some light on these issues
but since we know that was it we're
stuck wondering
let's have a look at these major plot
holes we can't stop thinking about
so lilith manages to end lucifer's life
using the spear of longinus
but hold up is that really all it takes
to end the life of the dark lord
we know that the spirit did work in
taking the life of an immortal before
so it's a valid idea but if that's the
case
why did lilith banish him as well she
said she'd sent him to the mortal world
but
where did he actually end up
unfortunately it's an answer we'll
likely never know
i'll have to take it
what we got from the show indicated that
lilith was probably ruling hell
since she did take down lucifer it would
make sense seems easy enough
but this is hell we're talking about
looking at her track record
the kings of hell weren't the biggest
fans of her so who is to say she gets
the throne for good
she was stripped of the throne once
before so it could happen again
you witches dare insult your dark lord
for most of us the fact that sabrina
passed away at the end of the final
season
is still pretty shocking but what
surprised us even more was that no one
tried to bring her back
throughout the series plenty of people
have been brought back to life
for better or worse so why at this time
was it too late for sabrina
they've got the cane pit master
necromancy skills from nick and ambrose
and summoning what's their excuse
we get that the banshees showed up but
after everything we're a bit surprised
we lost sabrina that quickly
anyone who knows how sabrina knows
they've always been
one in the same and then there was nick
talk about a dramatic finale oh nick
first of all it was strange that the
loss of such a major character would
happen
off-screen secondly how did he know he
would end up where sabrina was if he
swam in the sea of soros
he knew he would go to the afterlife
sure but where
they end up is a place no one has ever
been
he can't have been sure that he and
sabrina would end up together
sure it could be seen as romantic but
logically there isn't a lot of sense
there
oh the trinket man a character who
brought a whole lot of power and magic
yet seemingly didn't make much of a
difference or sense in the plot
why does he have pandora's box the imp
of perverse and the stone of umphalos
don't get us wrong it's super cool but
what exactly is his deal
chances are he might be some kind of god
he could also be the hp lovecraft
character
nier lethitep for now he remains a
mystery
of superb and sublime quality
for the collector of rare trinkets
what was lilith's boon the boon she was
expecting from mambo marie was supposed
to be a big deal yet
it got totally dropped in the series why
did we never hear about it again
we know it wasn't adam and since she
defeated lucifer it's not like there is
anything else that important she may
have wanted
yet another unanswered question adam and
i accept
sweet sweet salem such a brilliant
character whose end was
totally glossed over this is yet another
example of a significant
character coming to an end too quickly
leaving us with no
real conclusion for our favorite furry
companion
while the endless salem was with sabrina
morningstar when she broke through the
enchanted mirror
your mirror is that all why is that the
last we see
and hear and why does no one mention it
after the fact
if salem was sucked into the void his
complete lack of presence makes sense
we've got to talk about the void sorry
the sweet hereafter
that place that looks like the void
white room giant pictures and golden
frames and
all so what is this place is it the
materialization of an
alternate place witches could go for a
more pleasant afterlife as sabrina had
suggested
that would be really great for all
future witches but it's strange no one
but sabrina and
nick are there leading us to consider
that maybe this is a whole other
universe we haven't seen yet
unfortunately that's the last we'll see
of it
as we've seen now alternate universes
and time paradox have really made some
logistics complicated and leave us with
major plot holes one of the
aforementioned reasons could
help explain how sabrina escaped the
stone but from what we're given it's not
really clear if she escaped herself then
the other sabrina probably could have
done that
too right if someone helped her out who
was it was it
some other alternate world sabrina in
that case
we're looking at an endless loop of
sabrina's without any idea of where they
start
to simplify things we can just assume
god somehow helped sabrina escape
you're me how can you beat me and how
did you save me
now we know hell can be flippant but
there was one moment that made a second
guess what exactly was going on
throughout the season hell was on team
caliban
suddenly when sabrina punches caliban
hell starts
cheering for her
is one punch all it took to change your
mind hell
apparently they weren't that impressed
since they went right back to rooting
for caliban after there was never
any real reason for hell to support
sabrina so what was up with that one
moment
was it an act of generosity it doesn't
seem
quite in character
[Applause]
with riverdale characters making cameos
throughout the series
we didn't question penelope blossom
appearing however
what was a bit of a plot hole was why
prudence disguised herself as blossom
where and when had they met before the
fact would make things
extra complicated considering that to
use the glamour spell prudence would
have had to met penelope before
besides that penelope was also never
seen again so what was the significance
of prudence disguising herself as
blossom at all
a cameo for the sake of a cameo isn't
quite as satisfying as a cameo with a
purpose
this may not be an inconsistency on the
show itself
but it's too big an inconsistency
between the chilling adventures of
sabrina and riverdale worlds
ben button passed away in riverdale and
greendale
in different ways and seemingly
different times
sure we didn't see his demise in the
chilling adventures of sabrina but it's
pretty heavily implied
the only conclusion we can come up with
is that there are some
wild alternate universes we don't know
about
sabrina is impressive there's no denying
that
once she's 16 and at the academy of
unseen arts
most of her fellow students are decades
old
while they have been there for longer
they are significantly older than we'd
expect for students if this is the case
we can't imagine how long it would take
to get a phd in their world
why is the dark lord taunting mortals
we're not
questioning why he can he's the dark
lord
he can do whatever he wants but why
would he do it what
aside from cruel fun what's the point
for him there are so many other
priorities and things that actually
affect him
we're confused that there's no concrete
reason given for it he's a busy guy
wouldn't he have people or spirits for
that anyway
sabrina was resistant to the magic in
part one fair enough
when she did go to the academy she
wasn't often in class
weird but sure she does very well pretty
on par with her colleagues who've
studied and
embraced their powers for years longer
then she starts resurrecting people like
it's no big deal
none of this makes much sense in the
timeline of her magic journey
we enjoyed the series while it lasted
and are definitely bumped there won't be
another season that could potentially
wrap up some of the story lines and make
sense of the inconsistencies in the
series
what are your theories on these plot
holes is there one inconsistency you
can't shake
let us know in the comments if you
enjoyed
give us a like and make sure to
subscribe to our channel